people please know if you know you know
when people post things like oh yeah
positive abs only I'm positive gang and
all this it's impossible to be positive
ooh the time honest you have to protect
your mind it's really important to many
of us on social media before we brushed
our teeth when our bed were just
scrolling scrolling scrolling looking at
things and subconsciously we don't even
realize but we end up comparing
ourselves to a bunch of things wise man
once told me even comparisons lead to
unhappiness a bunch of things are trying
to access is if there's very important
we learn to protect it here's my five
tips as to how you can protect your mind
number one be honest with yourself it's
alright to say how you're feeling and
it's also okay to say no to certain
things listen me I'm gone like I say no
to a bunch of things these days
I'm not looking to go to no dinners to
spend any money with a bunch of people I
don't really know that well with food I
don't really like honesty is really
important you are a lot still sad
anxious angry upset you can fill a wide
range of emotions and that doesn't mean
you're being negative it means you're
being human step to recognizing what
affects your mind it's really important
I went to CBT that stands for cognitive
behavioral therapy where you understand
how your thoughts impact your feelings
and how your feelings impact your
actions if you can identify the things
in your life that are affecting you you
have more of a chance of addressing them
and dealing with the issues here's what
affects me if I don't talk about how I'm
feeling and I keep it bottled up inside
and something wrong happens I would then
link that problem to every other problem
in my life so I could have dropped my
phone on the screen smashed had a really
bad day at work and then come home and
found at the fridge is empty but one
thing I need to realize is every problem
I have in my life is an individualistic
problem and they're not linked to one
another and not something I do to myself
quite often is overwhelm myself with
situations that life isn't the world of
social media you know we have this
online playground we'll be all like to
present the perfect images of ourselves
that really
there are no certain people and then
happy all the time but they're posting
I'm projecting this really perfect image
and I'm like yo that's not possible all
the time so what I've decided to do is
take time away from that and do things
that really make me happy one thing that
really makes me have to be spending time
with my nephew mainly because he doesn't
care about anything that's going on in
the world besides playing with a
cardboard box and making a castle out of
it
step 3 disconnecting daily sometimes
it's really important for us to unplug
ourselves from what's going on in the
world modern life the way it is it's
moving a hundred miles an hour 24 hours
a day seven days a week we consume a lot
we eat a lot and we don't really do much
so it's important we take time for
ourselves we make time to sleep we make
time to think and we make time to get
physical and get active number four
connect with something that you and only
you love this could be anything
football poetry singing anything
get out your system having a passion
project can be really exhilarating and
that feeling you get you can't get that
from many things in life so whatever
gives you that harness there embrace it
protect it and most importantly live it
and number five reflecting on things
that you are grateful for
gratitude is a word that's very
underrated in today's world and I don't
believe we embrace it enough I try to
reflect on three things that I'm
grateful for on a daily basis and I'm
telling you the truth it makes me feel
better
the first thing I was grateful for that
happened to me today was being able to
open my eyes have it another opportunity
yellow second thing are they would
support petrol in my car
cuz I'm gonna live in broke for a long
time and now B now to put petrol in my
car that's a big deal for me and thirdly
I had lunch with my dad and that might
not seem like a big thing to a lot of
people but it's something I'm very
grateful for congratulate yourself and
be proud of how far you've come on this
journey of life I'm to say Manawa that
was my first steps into protecting your
mind I hope you find it useful let's be
the generation to change the narrative
let's help each other and be kind you
okay me left talk mental health
[Music]